absolutely I do want to have more kids  one day for sure that was Mila Kunis  earlier this year opening up to et about  wanting to expand her family with her  hubby Ashton Kutcher the actress got her  wish she's pregnant with their second  child and her growing baby bump is  seriously too cute here she is on  Wednesday in Beverly Hills the 33 year  old kept it casual in a 70s inspired  dress in white tennis shoes oh look we  like to think is a little nod to the  show that started it all  you wanna have my children well yeah  Ashton and Mila tied the knot last July  and welcomed their first child a  daughter named Wyatt in October 2014  here's what the bad mom star told et in  April about how motherhood has changed  her learn how to be like a great partner  and a great wife and a great woman and  be yourself and still be responsible for  you know a living child or but it's  definitely learning process